[Musique]
niché dans un écrin de verdure
saint-claude et la capitale du haut jura
accrochés aux flancs des montagnes qui
lancèrent à la confluence de deux
torrent la bienne et le tacon la ville
prend des allures de cité piémontaise
ici se sont développées des savoir faire
dont la patience et la ministre sont les
maîtres mots
[Musique]
équipier et diamantaire ont assuré et
assurent encore la renommée de la ville
[Musique]
dans son atelier sébastien vos perpétue
le savoir-faire et l'art des maîtres
pipiers antoine grenard a repris la
sphère familiale et dynamise l'image de
la ville
[Musique]
christophe guy est un des derniers
diamantaire en exercice il nous ouvre
ses portes fait rarissime dans une
profession qui cultive le secret
héritier de ses savoir faire philippe
vuillet remet aux ne cesse d'innover
dans la microtechnologie un marché
porteur qui repose sur l'ingéniosité et
la précision
[Musique]
l'esprit coopératif a largement marqué
l'histoire de la ville et d'une utopie
sociale a émergé la maison du peuple
roger bergeret se passionne pour cette
aventure collective
aujourd'hui encore l'esprit fraternel
continue de faire vibrer la ville une
vitalité créatrice dessine le vaisseau
d'une véritable épopée culturel
au bord de la falaise s'élève le musée
de l'abbaye valérie plus jeune
conservatrice nous y accueillent
[Musique]
proche tourmenté gorge cascades douces
rondeurs des pics acérés rythme le
relief jurassien
c'est dans ce territoire hostile qu'on
vème siècle de moine décide de se
retirer il y fonde un héritage qui au
fil des ans devient une abbaye attirés
par la protection qu'offrent les moines
les habitants des monts aux alentours
s'installe au pied de l'édifice c'est la
naissance de la ville aurélia bully
historienne médiéviste s'intéresse de
près aux origines de saint cloud on se
trouve ici dans le grand cloître de
l'abbaye qui est un espace
archéologiques qui a été révélé lors de
fouilles qui sont déroulés entre 1998 et
2003 alors ce cette galerie
est très importante elle a été édifiée
au xième siècle et elle avait deux
fonctions principales
une fonction de distribution des
édifices de la ville de saint-claude
elle permettait de rallier les deux
églises principales du monastère situé
de part et d'autre de ce grand couloir
qui de 110 mètres de long et cet espace
a également une fonction très importante
une fonction liturgique puisque les
moines
processionnelle en se rendant d'une
église à une autre pour les différents
offices de la journée en chantant les
louanges et en priant dans ce dans cet
espace qui est un des seuls espaces de
de ce type conserver encore en élévation
cet espace est une chapelle à vocation
mémorielle qui a été édifiée au 12e
siècle et c'est dans cet espace
précisément qu'il a été décidé lors la
construction du musée de présenter
l'histoire de cet habit de saint claude
alors pourquoi il fallait présenter
cette histoire est là et un caractère
tout à fait exceptionnel de par la
précocité la fondation de ceux de son
monastère les moines romain et le bessin
sont arrivés sur les lieux vers 430 est
ce qui a fait une de ses spécificités au
moyen-âge c'est la découverte du corps
d'un abbé mérovingiens saint-claude
corps découverts on disait on dit dans
les documents sans corruption
c'est-à-dire le corps a été conservé
intact ce qui a donné lieu à une série
de miracles et de la part des moines à
la promotion de ce pèlerinage c'est ce
qui a fait la prospérité
la reconnaissance de cet établissement à
la fin du moyen âge et jusqu'au xviiie
siècle alors c'est au xviiie siècle que
le des enjeux nouveaux vont apparaître
d'abord la conservation bira culte du
corps de saint claude on y croit de
moins en moins c'est l'époque des
lumières
par ailleurs les moines ont légué ses
dix ont une coutume qui est la coutume
de la main morte en effet les moines
étaient réputés les propriétaires
éminent de toute la terre de saint
claude et les habitants avaient été
réduits à l'état de serre ce système a
déchaîné l'opposition
certaines communautés qu'on appelle
demain portable et
crystal avocat christain et voltaire
sont venus au secours des mamours table
c'était un des derniers combats de
voltaire donc le combat à la fois pour
la reconnaissance du caractère
miraculeux de la conservation du corps
et contre la main morte ils vont se
faire en même temps durant le xviiie
siècle 5ce odette un passage de
contrebande entre la suisse voisine et
le royaume de france c'est par là que
transitent les écrits des philosophes
des lumières alors interdit par la cour
est le clergé
l'esprit des lumières insufflera un vent
progressistes sur la cité
en 2008 est inauguré le musée de
l'abbaye de l'histoire médiévale à la
peinture moderne il n'y a que quelques
marches le musée de l'abbaye qui est
l'un des derniers musées de france
ouvert en franche-comté présente une
collection d'art moderne disséminés dans
ses étages mais elle caractéristiques
intéressant de par son architecture à
cibl l'humaniste et contemporaine
l'architecte a delfau scaranello a
souhaité garder une partie transparente
en bas pour que nous ayons un regard sur
le voeu l'ancien monastère dans lequel
est logé le musée et cette partie
supérieure avec cette façade qui est un
clin d'oeil au travail on ferme du haut
jura à l'origine georges besson critique
et collectionneur d'art il est très
attaché à saint-claude sa ville natale
par amitié pour lui dit bart donne et
renier jaunisse de peintres léguerons
leurs collections au futur musée de
l'abbaye le repas des amis de paul
collomb est un tableau qui appartient à
la collection du centre georges pompidou
ce qui est intéressant dans ce tableau
c'est qu'il représente une famille
d'artistes une famille d'artistes autour
de georges besson qui est une figure
tout à fait importante critique d'art
collectionneurs d'art au début du 20e
siècle nous voyons dans ce tableau donc
georges besson sa seconde épouse
jacqueline prétendre et mais également
le donateur et peintre du musée en fait
qui a fait le don de ses tableaux au
musée du bardo
le salon bonnart est une salle
absolument central pour le musée
puisqu'elle réunit des oeuvres de pierre
bonnard né en 1867 qui affectionnait
tout particulièrement gaymard donne ses
oeuvres que nous avons déjà dans la
collection des dessins des offres nabi
réunis ce vraiment un ensemble tout à
fait cohérent où nous voyons plusieurs
périodes en fait pierre bonnard ici nous
sommes devant un tableau de 1945 le
jardin du cannet là nous avons un
travail vraiment
qui utilise sa palette de couleurs
extraordinaires son goût du cadrage
aussi puisqu'il devait beaucoup la
photographie il avait une manière de
cadres est tout à fait
particulière et personnelle et puis
cette manière de aussi de diffuser de
rendre diffuse en fait les couleurs les
unes par rapport aux autres donc là on
est vraiment dans un éclatement du
jardin au cannet c'est une vraiment de
plénitude c'est une oeuvre de maturité
pour bonnart qui décédera deux années
après
[Musique]
à la fin du 19e siècle saint cloud voix
l'essor des mouvements socialistes et
coopératif la vie des travailleurs
sanclaudien et transformé par la
création de coopératives à chaque
profession la sienne au tournant du
siècle dans un contexte tendu
ces initiatives prennent un chemin
singulier
[Musique]
ici les élans utopiste ont ouvert une
voie originale et concrète celle de la
maison du peuple
nous sommes ici dans la cour de la
maison du peuple un imposant bâtiment de
4500 m²
l'extraordinaire peut-être c'est que ce
bâtiment n'a pratiquement pas changé
depuis son inauguration en 1910 la
maison du peuple était construite sur un
ravin qui allait pratiquement jusqu'à la
vallée de la bienne donc nous sommes ici
pratiquement sûr du cru il ya encore
trois étages en dessous l'ensemble a
certainement une inspiration quelque peu
fouriériste puisque cette cour centrale
est fait de telle sorte que tous les
êtres les acteurs de cette maison de
cette ruche social se retrouvent ici se
croisent discute à la fois quand il
monte des sous sols où ils viennent des
ateliers par exemple de la boulangerie
industrielle
quand ils sortent du théâtre quand ils
sortent d'une réunion cafés quand ils
sortent des bureaux donc un lieu où l'on
se croise où l'on se rencontre
nous sommes ici dans un lieu d'invention
sociales l'école de saint cloud en quoi
consiste cette invention social est bien
le problème ou 19e siècle c'est avant
tout
l'accumulation du capital pour les
travailleurs et ne dispose que de leur
travail accumulé le capital comment est
bien par le groupement par l'association
et notamment par des coopératives avec
un système ingénieux mais difficile à
imposer finalement aux coopérateurs qui
n'y sont venus que peu à peu tous les
bénéfices sont versés à un fonds social
inaliénable ce fonds social servira à
créer des caisses sociales à une époque
où n'avaient pas d'assurances sociales
à créer des vagues des sociétés
d'agrément c'est à dire il ya un côté
évidemment culturel je dirais il faut se
distraire il faut du plaisir des moments
de plaisir et enfin à créer aussi des
d'autres coopératives c'est à dire à
étendre le mouvement
dans l'en dans l'espace à la à la fois à
la création de coopératives de
consommation mais aussi de coopérative
de production donc une la conception
d'une accumulation du capital aux mains
des travailleurs est finalement d'une
révolution qu'on pourrait dire une
révolution par le bas une révolution
horizontale en effet la devise de la
maison c'est les travailleurs se libérer
eux-mêmes
[Musique]
c'est
il
[Musique]
oh
c'est donc un centre culturel
pluridisciplinaire
puisqu'on touche à peu près toutes les
formes d'expression artistique
[Musique]
si tu viens le week-end dernier il ya
des visites aux archives de la maison du
peuple il ya un atelier sérigraphie dans
la cour il ya le coeur ouvriers qui en
train de répéter haut niveau -3 et qui
fait des interventions pendant l'après
midi c'est une dizaine de bénévoles qui
sont en train d'installer de préparer le
banquet
fraternel du soir c'est eux
lors qu'est ce qui est en train de faire
la balance avec les techniciens et puis
le soir le café qui est bondé et tout le
monde qui danse voilà ça c'est un côté
frac
et puis la veille il y avait le
surnatural orchestra 18 musiciens en
résidence pendant cinq jours accueillez
chez a chez l'habitant donc chez des
personnes bénévoles de la fraternelle
qui les ont vus évoluer puis travaillé
pendant pendant toute une semaine donc
c'est vrai que d accueil comme ça c'est
important puis dynamisant ça nourrit
quoi ça n'aurait les personnes qui font
vivre cette maison
[Musique]
une autre chose que j'aime c'est le voir
le bonheur
deux des gens qui viennent au spectacle
découvrir des choses qui ne passent pas
la télévision qui sont pas présentes
dans les médias il ya une vraie
rencontre entre les artistes et le
public
[Musique]
c'est la dynamique c'est la sociabilité
c'est la fraternité c'est
c'est tous les
jours qu'on peut construire ensemble
c'est le vivre ensemble peu importe le
niveau d'implication qu'en fait c'est
vraiment ce n'est laissé pour se faire
plaisir quand on est bénévole
c'est une ruche la frappe et cette
activité à la des répercussions
économiques c'est à dire que
contrairement à l'ensemble des centres
culturels de france nous nos produits
ils sont issus à 70 % de notre activité
et 30% de dotation d'argent public la
frappe ses cinquante mille entrées par
an tous secteurs confondus
dans une ville de 10 11 mille habitants
sur un bassin de vie de vingt mille
habitants c'est énorme regarde ça c'est
aussi un aspect fantastique ici on a une
fonction sociale et on remplit une
mission de service public clairement
mais on le fait je crois tous
dans le plaisir mais je crois que c'est
aussi ça un des fondements de la vie ici
c'est qu'on peut pas accueillir les gens
si on n'est pas soi même dans des
conditions
de de bonheur quoi tout simplement
oui
s'il est une profession qui s'est
largement engagé dans les mouvements
coopératifs
c'est celle des diamantaires pour
certains ils formaient l'aristocratie
prolétarienne saint-claude était alors
un centre incontournable de l'industrie
du diamant et se ranger à la 4e place
mondiale
christophe guy est un héritier de cette
histoire
[Musique]
là là là ce sont des liens se sont
détail voyant
toute l'industrie diamantaire est basée
sur le travail à façon c'est à dire que
les bons les donneurs d'ordre était
blanc précis le genevois où quelques
parisiens et les diamantaires simple aux
liens étaient des sous traitants si on
voulait faire un petit peu un historique
rapide faudrait dire révocation de
l'édit nantes les protestants qui
peuvent donc paris lé joaillier protée
les protestants qui paris s'installe à
genève
depuis genève si vous voulez sur le haut
jura ils savent qu effectivement une
main d'oeuvre qualifiée puisque on fait
déjà de l'horlogerie est donc tout
naturellement ils se disent bombe
puisque sondés puisque la main d'oeuvre
est déjà habitué à la minutie doivent
être capable de tailler le diamant et
puis on avait aussi un autre avantage
ces des cours d'eau qui amenait la
motricité donc ces deux ces deux
avantages qui ont fait que finalement le
métier diamantaire s'est implanté dans
le haut-jura grâce grâce aussi aux
genevois principalement avant 1914 c'est
à dire au moment où les taillerie serait
plaint dans le jura voilà un petit peu
le genre de matériel qui était utilisé
donc là
koki en bronze plomb ont fait chauffer
le plan concerté la pierre à l'intérieur
sertie de diamants bruts et ont fait une
facette on réchauffe ronde srt la pierre
on l'a ressortie ensuite on fait une
deuxième phase est donc imaginé un petit
peu là là là le temps qu'il fallait pour
tailler une pierre dessus dessous ça ce
sont les derniers dope si vous voulez
bondé qui ont été utilisés à saint
claude dans les années 60 est davantage
c'était bon effectivement il y avait un
niveau et puis il y avait surtout des
diviseurs les diviseurs ça c'était
quelque chose d'extraordinaire parce que
ça permettait d'améliorer nettement le
rendement on faisait la première phase
est on là carey et ensuite on tournait
et 11 aides ont pesé en faisait la mise
en 8 la même chose pour le brillant
talich donc ça c'était celle ça vraiment
révolutionné le métier pour ce genre de
me2 le matériel
dans les années 60 il ya commencé à y
avoir une concurrence indienne 65 64 65
bon les indiens ont commencé à tailler
des marchandises des petites
marchandises il était plutôt mieux placé
que nous déjà à l'époque ben may taille
est moins bien donc on arrivait quand
même à s'en sortir c'est à dire il y
avait la qualité française qui faisait
que c'était lé joaillier préfére
effectivement acheter de meilleurs que
le meilleur aux marchandises mais il y
en a un certain nombre qui existe est
surtout un prix et ces gens là ont
commencé à acheter aux indiens mais les
indiens sont pas plus bêtes que les
antilles sont développés sont améliorées
et ils sont arrivés à faire détail qui
était tout à fait comparable aux tailles
que l'on sait à saint-claude et à partir
de ce moment la bombe nous le métier a
commencé à péricliter en terme de deux
ouvriers si vous voulez c'est que on
était trop comment c'est trop cher on
était trop cher de 10 15% 10 15% dans
une pierre mouvants de l'épée à sa passe
pas on a été les premières victimes de
la mondialisation
à l'égal du diamant la pub est
emblématique de la ville cette activité
a employé jusqu'à 4000 personnes
[Musique]
sebastian beaux jeunes maîtres pipiers
s'est installé dans un ancien atelier
j'ai commencé à travailler dans cet
atelier d'étude jeunots quand j'étais
étudiant
ensuite j'ai trouvé du travail chez un
collègue qui m'a embauché pour l'année à
plein temps
on apprend le travail de pi pied sur le
tas et ensuite il ya dix ans j'ai repris
la suite de mon ancien patron
[Musique]
chaumière application de la pub parce
que j'aimais bien le travail du bois et
puis c'est un objet qui nous fait
beaucoup l'api possible
c'est un métier qui est
variée ici surtout comment des années
que deux à travailler on fait vraiment
la pipe du début à la fin
on fait aussi la visite de l'atelier
ça nous permet de rencontrer beaucoup de
gens différents et donc d'apprendre
toujours en discutant avec eux
moi je mets un triplé dimanche quand
j'ai le temps
fumer la pipe c'est quelque chose qu'on
qu'on fait quand on a un moment pour se
poser vraiment pas ce que ça prend du
temps parce que justement l'intérêt
c'est sera l'axé puis de se concentrer
sur la combustion du tabac et puis le
goût de la fumée et c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut faire uniquement quand on a
un moment de loisir
commissaire maigret capitaine haddock
sherlock holmes van gogh celle du
grognard du sapeur dit poète ou du
peintre nom d'une pipe chaque pippa une
histoire en voilà une récente voilà la
peep show comme sphère qui a une
histoire
quand même depuis depuis 2005 maintenant
ou 2006 2005 c'est c'était la première
année quand je suis revenu de d'irlande
pour travailler chez chapuis que moi
c'est
en septembre 2005 mon père m'appelle me
dit écoute antoine qu'est ce qu'on va
faire de cette entreprise de pipes et
moi je voulais bien revenir à saint
claude et là il m'a dit écoute je te
rappelle dans 24 heures tu me dis quoi
tu me dis qu'est ce que tu veux faire si
tu veux revenir ou pas il m'a appelé 24
heures après puis je vais dire les
banques où on retourne à saint claude
donc ensuite il fallait réagir il
fallait faire des travailler dur parce
que ce n'était pas une situation
favorable pour l'entreprise donc on a
fait ce genre de produits ça a beaucoup
fait parler de nous et on les a vendus
donc c'était plutôt pas mal même si à
chaque homme est connu principalement
pour du traditionnel et là on revendique
maintenant le traditionnel et le moderne
en même temps
[Musique]
la force de saint-claude est de savoir
s'adapter de répondre aux nouvelles
attentes
certains ont fait le pari de se
concentrer sur la microtechnologie une
branche industrielle complexe qui
nécessite une minutie exceptionnel
ça c'est un instrument de mesures pour
contrôler des vibrations
c'est de
mettre des capteurs et il enregistre les
mouvements du sol avec ça c'est pour le
laboratoire national de métrologie où il
ya le kilo et allons à paris donc c'est
un c'est un seul morceau de dassier
samse du bronze béryllium et tout
articulé toutes les petites
articulations
elles sont 30 microns phuc a plus ou
moins d'un micron on a fait deux
exemplaires de cette pièce là en fait ça
sert à rien de se battre sur des écoutes
pièces vêtements sur des coups de pompe
on pourra jamais nous
à voir les prix chinois jamais c'est
même pas la peine d'essayer donc il faut
se battre il faut se battre sur des
péniches ou c'est compliqué puis c'est
compliqué moyen de concurrence plus on
peut monnayer notre notre savoir-faire
en
97 98 quand on a fait construire une
usine là on travaillait
localement on avait des nanars donc
était dans un rayon de 15 km on
travaillait pour le jouer on travaille
pour l'automobile pour la téléphonie en
99 98 99 les donneurs d'ordres
dans la téléphonie ont décidé de
délocaliser en chine et nous on faisait
plus de 80% avec un client dans
téléphonie on était on était spécialiste
un peu des façades d'avant de téléphone
donc on a décidé de se tourner vers le
micro parce qu'à l'époque cherchait déjà
des faire des petits trous à faire des
choses un peu que qui sortent un peu de
l'ordinaire et on trouvait personne on a
dit tiens il ya peut-être un créneau à
prendre dans de ce côté là et
aujourd'hui on injecte un millième de g
on fait à peu près 20 pièces dans un
grain de matière pour ceux qui sont au
courant et on fait du sur moulage aussi
de très petites pièces en injectant
surmoulage 1 25000e de gramme de matière
on fait des micros outils des cours ont
fait de l'usinage de pièces de grande
précision en fait on est le spécialiste
des canards à trois pattes capte les
jeux les gens veulent un trou de 15
microns on est capable de le faire car
l'usinage cinq axes avec des fraises de
huit centièmes huit centièmes c'est à
peine plus gros qu'un cheveu on est
capable de le faire ici c'est ce qui
fait notre différence en fait on a du
plaisir à faire notre métier parce que
en fait chaque chose est un challenge
charles choc chaque fois qu'on a un
client qui nous amène quelque chose à
faire on sait que on sait qu'il va
falloir faire travailler la tête en plus
c'est toute la combine c'est tout ah ben
tiens à cette pièce là fort on a fait
comme ça reste fois on a des données
d'autres équipements on va peut-être la
faire autrement et toutes les réflexions
en fait c'est ce qui est passionnant
dans notre métier
riche d'une histoire culturelle sociale
artisanale et industrielle
consciente des origines de son essor
saint-claude s'est adapté aux défis qui
lui ont été imposées et est prête à
relever ce que lui réserve l'avenir
[Musique]
samedi prochain dans pourquoi chercher
plus loin
[Musique]